just now with more reaction all of this
uh is the host of a brand new show right
here on the fox news channel
well it's certainly not going to be
called filtered with dan bongino he
doesn't even know what that means
but unfiltered with dan bongino saturday
night's 10 o'clock
it opened to huge rating debut dan
congratulations we couldn't be more
proud of you
um thank you my friend let's talk about
this issue but more importantly let's
talk about something even bigger
is not only are democrats allowing this
lawlessness to occur
they are facilitating it whether it's a
sanctuary city or state
or whether it's joe and kamala not only
are they not enforcing
our laws on immigration they're
facilitating they're aiding and abetting
they are providing transportation to
other states they are
providing the cages for the kids in the
middle of a pandemic that we saw that
was so overcrowded
now why do i believe if you break the
law
i break the law people watching break
the law we go to jail
well that's because the democrats are
hypocrites i mean they're whole legit
sean they don't even believe in their
own agenda just quickly on the open
borders front
you know they figured out a long time
ago that they can't possibly win
elections anymore because they're losing
working class voters
this has nothing to do with immigration
this is all about power to democrats
it's all about power i think a few years
ago i forget who it was maybe it was ted
cruz i'm not sure but someone put
an amendment in an immigration bill that
said i don't me
i don't know if it was cruz i don't want
to get ahead of myself but i know
someone put an amendment in it said
listen
you can stay here if you're here
illegally
but you can't vote for 10 years or
something and the democrats said no no
we don't want that
which shows you conclusively this has
nothing to do
with you know being compassionate to
people here illegally
there's nothing to do with any of that
this is all about power but sean
their agenda's crap they don't even
believe in their own agenda they're
total frauds think about it right
they they preach higher taxes right yet
john kerry
bernie sanders they don't voluntarily
pay a dime in higher taxes they're
totally full of it
they preach this defunding the police i
was just reading this story about corey
bush
this member of the squad who's paying
for private security
i mean they're totally full of it
remember obamacare oh we love obamacare
government health care
and then when they try to say okay you
guys up in the senate and the congress
have to use obamacare they were like
screw that we don't want that crap
that's just for the that's for the
losers the deplorables out there
i mean these people are frauds that's
what they're all about and you know you
get away with that
they get away with it on a lot of issues
here you know i i don't understand
well i guess probably i do the the
democratic party
this is just this dual system of justice
that we have
for example michael horowitz can refer
people for lying to congress
nobody's held accountable uh you know
but if you're a republican
another system of justice exists for you
but if you look at i don't care
you know how does joe biden allow a a
waiver for vladimir putin to build his
pipeline
but then fire people with the stroke of
a pen building the keystone xl pipeline
you know how does he raise the price of
oil and energy
and everybody's feeling the impact of it
and then go out and lie and say oh it's
not going to impact you
you know it seems like we're living in a
time where up is down down is up and
anything that is said is just echoed by
the mainstream media
i did not plan this i promise that is an
awesome question
that they told us what the democrats
right and their lunatic friends in the
media
they told us for three and four years
that vladimir putin
you know was giving trump back rubs and
they colluded to win an election that's
what they told us right
and yet i was going to cover this
tomorrow on my podcast
politico wrote a piece literally i have
it right here here it is
politico remember this one from uh 2017
ukrainian efforts to sabotage trump
backfire i'm going to cover this
tomorrow
the political the left-wing side that
was mistaken january
of 2017. wow that
you got a good january 11th good job i'm
impressed
and you were that's very by kenneth
vogel you can look it up folks
he wrote that piece about hannity is a
loser
that's what that means no no no no it
means you paid attention
but this they write an article about
foreign interference in elections
rudy giuliani says hey were you guys
interfering in elections and they
investigate rudy giuliani
i mean it's like you're right this is
like bizarro superman land
everybody dnc operative everything's
backwards you have the dnc operative
going to the ukrainian embassy in
washington dc
what for the very purpose of digging up
dirt
then of course we've got zero experience
hunter on top of all of that
he's getting money from russia from
kazakhstan from
chinese nationals from the chinese
government uh
and of course ukraine okay and he says
in his email
sean he says in his email that that he's
doing he's been business
with the quote spy chief from china and
liberals are like ah no big deal
it's hunter lunch bucket joe's kid no
worries at all
these people are total phonies they're a
laughingstock what a joke
okay why would anybody think that dan
bongino is ever going to be filtered
i i i'm looking i'm looking at the name
of your new show and it says
unfiltered with dan bongino which okay
but
i don't think there is any other bongino
that exists
no it just why don't we just say bongino
and you know what you're going to get
because you're not
getting filtered ever it's like phil are
we going to filter
mark levin ever under any circumstances
no
it's not going to happen congratulations
listen you know i'm the same way off the
air too oh i know definitely unfiltered
all the time
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else